oh oh oh oh eu indagou o início e uso do
solo que está a passar muita josé coelho
e josé coelho
ok esta parece ser a sala do fat
freddy's 11 o hospital ele também era o
capitão era o capital não sei se é que
vai ganhar um estrago não fosse um erro
em cima
ok olá a todos pessoal de quem fala é o
dar que seja muito em mim jamais um
vídeo e o estrago de que vai finais é
fredes 2 que hoje você já não estou a
pedir há muito muito tempo eu confesso
que também estou super ansioso por
suplementares no fight night at freddy's
e fez um bem pessoal que a vossa frente
vocês têm já os novos animatronics
completamente mutilados que josé pinto
josé coelho e os é fred mas com o
espectro de enfrenta assim com aspecto
mais infantil mas está bizarro na mesma
e reparem que isto ao piscar voa por
cento e metrô ônibus antigos por estado
buraco é que tanta certeza pessoal é
este jogo supostamente iria sair em 2015
mas eu encontrei nesse time e comprei
logo é e supostamente também se um demo
não sei sistema estão já à noite todas
os itens op maria segunda méxico
qualquer forma se um de um free que
vocês podem baixar na descrição e é esse
pessoal poderão ainda experimentar este
fascinante 7 fred se o que aconteceu ao
início eu não sei se posso também tem um
easter egg ou não os supostamente vai
acontecer a todos ou só algumas pessoas
não saiu pois vão investigar isso nós
foi um estrago fico muito contente por
ter acontecido já na primeira vez que o
início do jogo mas por lá então pessoal
dar 1 mil km vamos lá ver o que é que
lhe espera nesses tribunais e freire
ok é pizzaria tem uma nova vida vai
fazer parte da nova cara do do fred
phelps vilas bisa o que poderá dar
errado algo assim parecido como o meu
espaço parece muito maior agora
não esquecendo só que eu sou um
segurança que estava dentro da pizzaria
e vou dar muita calma chamada porque não
quero saber o que vai dizer ok lusa
nós agora só temos luz e deixou as
portas meu camarim eu quero ver as
câmeras eu sou aqui todos e reparem que
nós temos muito mais câmeras não muito
mas não acho que só temos mais quatro é
isso ou blog pessoal estatutário paulo
o que continuamos a ter aqui as nossas
mesas de festa como sempre tivemos está
pronta logo aí está um clique
ok tudo tranquilo por agora vão china
que eu só saí eu antes duas portas e
alguém vai estar cada dia à frente de
rússia e alguém vai sair daqui do escuro
e vai mostrar pra cima eu saí porque eu
vi isso no trailer eu visse supostamente
irá se nos raposas né
eu acho que sim ok tá é muito escuro e
ainda estão aqui todos por isso não as
trevas não esquecem pessoal também que
nós temos na noite um supostamente é
sempre mais fácil é sempre à noite um
deus movimento - e isto é o que esteve
em relação a steck supostamente é isso
né
o fofo gol eu não tinha mais criando
freire
o fred é porta então supostamente vou
ter que esconder aqui porque não sei se
vocês sabem pessoal porque no flat fred
sun supostamente eles atacavam diz
porque eles achavam que nós era um
esqueleto fora do seu corpo é exposto em
mente é que nós já conseguimos nos
esconder dentro do fred
supostamente é isso é isso os alunos
podem ficar porque nós já somos um
esqueleto dentro de um corpo então faz
sentido de ver algumas histórias de
algumas coisas sobre as teorias do
fagner 7 fredes e por causa do vício e
isso é muito importante porque deus não
comete fraudes um solo já está com
porque pensam que nós somos um esqueleto
que não tem corpo como eu só tenho o
corpo de josé coelho serra após 12 e os
josés todos né isso ok vamos lá ver seu
cheiro aqui não saíram tatu tranquilo
ok ok press
em outro ponto alto isso faz oito ou o
meu partido supostamente esteve inflação
né
eu acho que sim ok nós conseguimos ver
um site tmz por serem a porta o que já é
muito burro
ele falou comigo do time eu quero
continuar a buscar o filho dele o
palhaço eu não tinha visto isto eu sei
por quê
o uso é conhecido lá você é conhecido lá
calma calma dar calma vamos fazer na
ventilação é que né não na seqüência eo
lá está aqui eu tô aqui enfim está na
guitarra
eu quero é ser conectar os raposas meu
não viram que o tiraram da equipe
raposas que está aqui tudo perdido mas
supostamente não é este aqui é um branco
me o que está acontecendo ou capital e
em todo estado isto é um não sei se
deveria mexer porque seus também vendo é
então eu vou ficar quieto fred falou com
a banda lá eu não sei por que eu tenho
que fazer isso supostamente aparece uma
lei o aviso é isso aqui dentro ninguém
me faz mal é isso
só não sei por que o comportamento do
sistema de porta e saiu por cima daqui
eu não sei que tenho que fazer é só pra
só porque eu sei qual está ali meu o
guga eu tenho que ir lá acima de
qualquer forma eu tenho que ir lá acima
de qualquer forma calma
não calma como é que o fluxo de saída de
coelho
o odolir cama
eu estava entre os demais que
supostamente não pode fazer uma aula
calma calma calma eu tenho que eu tenho
que provar isto é né
eu não sei por que esteja tudo bem que o
peso da mesma escolhi meus problemas
como nós comemos com amigos comigo mesmo
tempo né
josé pinto também é meu o que caraças
prova seria outro rodeado é a primeira
noite eu tô às cinco da manhã
esta noite o rei e eu acho que sim né
[Aplausos]
é então é só a gente ficar porque com
esta primeira experiência do fight 7
fredes e pelos vistos nós temos a
segunda noite por isso se quiserem ver a
segunda noite ainda hoje ainda hoje
muitas quando a noite já seja apoiar em
estúdio por isso deixa o voto forte
apoio leque favorito musical não quer
saber e é isso ao fiquem bem e até a
próxima
[Música]